[Music]
I've just finished watching gamra
rebirth and it's better than expected so
this video here will be a non-spoiler
review and we will discuss the general
theme and what to expect from the show
and for those who haven't seen it yet
please do and for those who have will
Hush Hush let it simmer for a while and
we'll get into more details after a few
few days so let's get
talking so prepare to be transported
back in time to the late 1980s as gamra
rebirth takes you on a ride through
Nostalgia intertwined with ancient
secrets and all inspiring kiju
encounters set in the year 1989 this
anime series offers a refreshing
departure from the high-tech smartphone
fil World we've become accustomed to in
recent years with flashbacks to distant
errors and references to the 20th
century discovery of the Kaiju this
Show's timeline is as intricate as if it
is
captivating at the core of this epic
Saga lies a Timeless theme the enigmatic
connection between a colossal gamra and
a young child this heartwarming born has
been the Hallmark of every Guma story
and it takes Center Stage once more The
Narrative seamlessly shifts between the
trials of the children and The Colossal
Kaiju weaving emotional drama and
breathtaking monster Batts into the
fabric of the storyline this delves deep
into profound themes exploring the
essence of life the power of friendship
and the moral imper to do what's right
regardless of the consequences it serves
as a reminder that turning a blind eye
to a problem can lead to dire
consequences even more harshly than when
you confront the problem
itself the series boasts a riveting
storyline that keeps you on the edge of
your seat even when you anticipate the
emergence of certain Kaiju or Monsters
the element of surprise prevails the
human characters and their narratives
defy conventional expectations and by
the time you reach the serious
conclusion every Det detail from the
very first episode falls into place
gamra rebirth is a true Masterpiece in
storytelling offering a meticulously
woven tapestry of interconnected events
and while the series trailer and
promotional posters hdden at Gamera
facing off against five different Kaiju
viewers may be in for a few extra
surprises in the Monstrous lineup the
anime series excels in depicting complex
interpersonal relationships that feel
astonishingly real the characters are
portrayed with such depth and nuance
that you can't help but empathize with
them even the villains earn a slice of
your empathy or sympathy gar rebirth
delivers a roller coaster of emotions
from moments of sorrow and joy to
Elation and frustration all wrapped up
in a shroud of suspense but be prepared
for heart-wrenching losses and tragic
turns that will leave you emotionally
invested and utterly captivated the
series will manipulate your emotions
just like you know a dog playing with a
ball or a steak so the series breaths
new life into to the origins of the kaju
offering a fresh new perspective while
preserving the essence of the earlier
movies and Comics while the origin story
is original it stays true to its roots
paying homage to the source material
there's also the introduction of a
clandestine organization that mirrors
the real world concept of the deep state
with hidden motives centered on
population control extermination and
racial Supremacy this Shadow group
gradually reveals its true colors as the
series unfolds each episode drops subtle
hints about its Sinister agenda keeping
viewers on their toes and certain
characters of that organization will be
akin to world leaders that you have seen
before for instance there is one woman
from that organization from that evil
organization and one look at her you
would instantly think oh it's Angela
Merkel so fans of gamra will not be
disappointed with this incarnation of
the giant flying turtle Kaiju gamera's
colossal size allows for awesome Kaiju
fights as well as for intricate and
intimate interactions with human
characters adding depth to his character
he retains all his classic powers and
even gains new ones but he's far from
being a Mary Sue character gamra will
face challenges will endure setbacks
will bleed and suffer yet ultimately
Triumph making him a compelling and
relatable protagonist the animation
style as well draws inspiration from
Godzilla Earth and Pacific Rim the black
but it elevates the concept to a new
level of refinement the Kaiju designs
are a sight to behold intricately
detailed and all inspiring but in
contrast the human characters feature
simpler designs though this is one
setback they could have improved facial
animations that could have better
conveyed their emotions nevertheless the
overall visual experience is captivating
so go check out the show and support the
Kaiju we have come to the end of this 5
Minute non-spoiler review and I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash smash
the Bell icon for regular updates and
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care
fam